[Music]
my name is Ryan Greg I'm a product
manager on the surrealist team and Anki
native March Marnie I'm one of the
technical program managers looking after
service at Google before we get started
I just wanted to take a quick audience
poll and say how many of you use
communities cool you're right but you're
in the right session
how many of you are developers on
kubernetes you're writing apps that run
on the platform okay
how many of you are operators of
kubernetes you make sure that other
people's apps work I see a lot of people
who raise their hands both occasions
that's right yeah and then if you didn't
raise your hand what are you doing here
all right all right so the session is
called kubernetes or run service
everywhere I want to break down the we
will get to the everywhere portion in a
minute but I want to break down the
service first a part little and kind of
TZ into the conversation after that to a
large degree today if you talk to people
in the community serve less equals
function you you push some code to the
cloud and you have it execute over there
but is it really the case is serve less
only a function as a service offering
that's kind of the question I'm posing
to you so developers I think the to a
large degree they the properties of
servlets are pretty commonly understood
today and they break down into two
separate things first of all is the
operational mode how you run serve less
maybe not develop but run their service
so first of all you shouldn't have to
worry about is the server's underneath
its write in a name and I think we can
argue about that the other thing is that
it also comes with certain level of
trust which means when you push your
code and execute on a framework that you
do not provide that there is a certain
amount of security that's integrated and
managed for you so you don't have to
worry about that either and that you
paying only for what you're when you use
that service when you when you're
actually doing something more
importantly you do not pay when it's not
doing something like so the code is just
sleeps
not doing anything it you shouldn't pay
for that so that's the operational model
in the programming model that the
developer experience on a service
platform we ideally have a service based
development model so you call API so you
don't run a bunch of scripts that just
you know you have to move over and
define a bunch of environment variables
and all that and it's event-driven so
you don't write all kinds of code to
keep watching is the file there yet
is there file yet there yet is the file
there yet but you actually are
subscribing to an event is there far
tell me when the file arrives and I will
fire something that's these five are
pretty well understood and most people
are agree with the same thing over and
with with those properties or service
what what I would like to add in here is
one more
and that's portability and I think
because you're in a session where which
title runs herbalist everywhere you
assume portability is important to you
so portability is more than just being
able to take that code that you have
built in one platform and able to take
it somewhere else and run its on another
platform it's about being able to expect
the same developer experience on each
one of those platforms so for example
the cloud run service that we announced
this week cloud run on that is managed
and hosted hosted and cloud run that
runs on gke the same developer
experience so not only being able to
move this from one platform one Operator
to another but being able to depend and
being able to benefit from the
innovation that that cloud service
providers offers for you and not having
have to the other important aspect of
that of being portability is that you
don't have to make a choice when day one
when you start thinking you have this
great idea and you're gonna write some
code
you shouldn't have to at that point say
I'm gonna write code that's gonna run on
a platform X you should be able to use
your idiomatic developer experience it's
idiomatic is just fancy word for natural
it just came you know you don't have to
learn any special the way you developing
go or no js' applications right now is
the very same way you should be able to
develop those applications for service
now that means also that you should be
able to preserve
the investment there are technologies
nowadays coming and going every month
and if we ask you to learn yet another
framework or yet another set of api's
that you know my may here may be here
tomorrow or not it's not very it doesn't
preserve your skill so you have to
continuously learn your skills with
servlets we hoping that the experience
is so portable that not only the
technology and the and the tooling is
portable to another environment but you
actually are able to take your skills
and be very productive in another
platform because the set of experiences
that are exposed to you as a developer
are one and the same so I think at this
point I think we would agree that
surplice is bigger than just a function
and I would pose at this point that
service is also bigger than just compute
if you go if you look today at GCP and
the number of the portfolio of service
offerings on Google they span from
everything from data and analytics
products machine learning and some curve
AI our Message Queuing is serve less or
even the developer experience so DevOps
tooling is service and you might have
seen some of that yesterday during the
keynote in developer for evening session
session so bigger than function bigger
than compute and able to benefit and
kind of comprise them with the same
developer experience all right I want to
ask Ryan now to talk about service
uncommon aids thanks mark so what about
serverless on kubernetes that's an
interesting idea first of all I think
everybody in here because your
kubernetes operators or developers
except for those of you who I don't know
why are here understand that kubernetes
is really the de-facto platform now for
running containers on the cloud on from
anywhere that you want to take those
workloads in fact there's a giant
ecosystem with pretty much every cloud
provider major and minor participating
in running a certified kubernetes
instance kubernetes has really taken off
over the last four years and become a de
facto way of doing container
orchestration but what does it really
look like when you break it down
urban ideas for operators it's done a
lot to improve
the operator experience for running
containers it's taken care of the needs
of scheduling and lifecycle discovery
load balancing storage all the things
that you had to worry about and manage
and operate on your own before kerbin
ideas has done a lot to make that easier
more straightforward and and simpler
there's a simple and kubernetes anyway
there's a broad number of features that
the polling - this all these great
things that you can do and the really
great thing that kubernetes has done is
its created this even platform across
all the different environments where you
can run so the learnings and the
knowledge that you look that you adopt
that's part of using kubernetes apply
whether you're running a community is on
google kubernetes on Prem or somewhere
else in another cloud for the developer
though you know developers really just
want to write code that's the core
business value that they provide but if
you're building on top of kubernetes
there's all these other things that you
have to do you have to containerize your
application you have to figure out how
to upload that application into a
container registry you have to actually
deploy the service create the deployment
and all the underlying objects inside
the kubernetes api you didn't have to
figure out how to expose that to the
internet or to your service mash or to
whatever the ingress gateway that you're
going to be using is you have to set up
logging and monitoring and deal with all
of these aspects and then you have to
figure out how to properly scale your
workload you might have an i/o bound
workload where you could put a lot of
concurrency into it or you might have a
CPU bound workload where you need to do
you know more horizontal scaling there's
a lot there and a lot more of it than
just writing code so earlier this week
we introduced cloud run which is this
concept of bringing service to
containers and trying to remove a bunch
of the details of the infrastructure and
what underlies what it takes to run one
of these containers in the cloud and
cloud run is available as a fully hosted
service so you don't have the kubernetes
aspect you don't have to worry about any
of the details of what cluster it's
running in how it's horizontally scaled
you just provide the container into
Google Cloud and we go run it for you
giving you a URL that you can access
give
you SSL all of the benefits of running
on a service platform which is great but
all of you aren't running on a service
platform you're running on kubernetes so
we didn't want to leave you out so we
also brought cloud run on G K which is
the same great cloud run experience for
the developer but running on top of
kubernetes engine so it gives you the
flexibility to continue you the
kubernetes investment that you've
already made but to get all of the
benefits of service for your developers
things like automatic scale easy
deployment network programming an
automatic participation in the service
mesh are all features provided by cloud
run on gke it also integrates with all
of the kubernetes features so using
policy management so it's called can't
remember the name of that feature which
we announced this week the ability to
manage these things everything that you
do with carbonite is today applies to
cloud run on gke because it's running on
top of your existing infrastructure it
also means you can take advantage of the
features of kubernetes on GK like custom
nodes being able to bring in custom
machine sizes bringing able to access
hardware accelerators like GPUs and TP
use all the advanced computers that are
available in the kubernetes platform
that aren't necessarily available on a
server list platform are yours on cloud
or 9 gke so we now have the ability to
offer server lists anywhere between a
fully service platform that's managed
through cloud run where everything is
hidden from you and you don't have to
worry about the details to quadrant on
gke where we manage the control plane
and provide the same developer
experience but it runs inside kubernetes
engine and Kay native which is the open
source platform that makes all of this
possible which allows you to run the
same API the same control plane on any
kubernetes installation anywhere so you
can have the same service experience
across the board from fully managed all
the way to do it yourself with open
source so let's step back and take a
look at this picture again with cloud
run on top of gke now developers really
can just focus on writing their code
they can have that service developer
experience
and still run it on top of all of your
kubernetes infrastructure and they don't
need to worry about all of those other
concerns so they can be more productive
and get more done let's go a little bit
deeper though because this is a 200
level talk and talk about what are the
actual benefits that you get out of
using quadrant on gke so when I deploy
my container on quadrant on gke using
the service infrastructure on kubernetes
engine I get my container automatically
scaled including scaling to zero so we
look at the HTTP traffic that is coming
into this service and if there isn't any
after a period of time the container
will timeout will spin down the pod and
it's taking up no resources inside your
cluster when a request comes in it lands
on an activator component which
understands which which service
definitions we need to go spin up will
create a pod or multiple pods depending
on how much traffic is coming in and
start routing the connections directly
to those instances and will scale up
from one obviously it's as many as it
takes to serve the load that you have
and there are some parameters that you
can use to fine-tune how that scaling
works
we also offer manage configurations and
revisions so we keep track of every
revision of a service that is deployed
through cloud run on GK and you can
easily move between them you can roll
back to an older version so you'd deploy
something new and it's and there's an
error you can quickly revert back we
also ensure that while we're moving over
to the new revision there's no downtime
requests that are coming in seamlessly
get migrated from one instance and one
version to the next one so your service
can remain live in production as you
deploy a new version we also integrate
with the SPO service mesh because we're
running on kubernetes so every service
that's deployed through cloud run on gke
is a member of the service mesh and you
can choose to expose that service either
externally outside the cluster or only
on the surface mesh if you want to do an
internal service that marks going to do
a really cool demo about that in a
little bit and then another great
benefit of cadre and gke
is that it enables the custom domains
story and certificate management story
on top of the cluster for server love
services so we automatically generate
URLs for those services that can be on a
custom domain name so that you don't
have to worry about all of the plumbing
to make that happen
and then of course cloud run on gke is
built on top of gke so it can connect
into a bunch of great GCP services like
cloud build and stack driver for doing
logging and monitoring but it's also a
pluggable infrastructure so if you want
to extend it with a partner integration
like data dog you can do that if that's
what your business depends on or you can
use get lab as the CI CD system and
we'll show you a little bit more about
how that works here in a little bit so
let me give you a demo of what this
actually looks like just to get a little
bit more real than me talking so if we
could switch to demo one Here I am in
cloud console this probably looks very
familiar to everybody here and I'm gonna
go into kubernetes engine just to show
you what it looks like to stand this up
so I will create a cluster wait for my
UI to load and I'm going to go ahead and
create a highly available cluster
because that's what you should be using
a few of production workloads and I'm
gonna scroll down to the bottom and I'm
going to turn on stackdriver logging and
monitoring turn on Sto
and I'm going to turn on cloud run ng
key and I'm not actually gonna click
create because it takes a little bit too
long for demo but that's how easy it is
to stand up a cluster that cloud run on
GCE can run on today you can only do
that when you create a cluster but very
soon will give you the option of doing
that on an existing cluster as well and
once I have it running I can move over
to the cloud run UI now and this is
really the developer experience for
deploying applications into this
environment if you think of the
kubernetes engine control plane as being
the operator experience on kubernetes
cloud run gives you the developer
experience on top of cloud run on GK and
I can just click to create a service I
can browse to find a container image in
this case I pick this one seems like the
right sha to me and I will choose to put
this into my kubernetes engine cluster
instead of into the manager namespace
and I'll just use default I'll say that
I wanted to be exposed externally so
that I can actually show you what
service I have deployed and I'll click
create and what's this what this is
doing right now is using the key native
API to go out and define a key native
service on this cluster
and under the covers k native is doing
all of the work necessary to create the
activator manage the routing program sto
to enable the the URL that I have here
to work and making the whole system up
and running and now you can see my
revision is deployed and ready for me to
activate I'll click on that and you can
see here's my my PDF service if you came
to the developer keynote last night
you'll be like hey I saw this before but
this is just a micro service that allows
you to convert a word document into a
PDF
very simple you can see that it's
running on quadrant on gke I can
actually go back and deploy the same
service on to the hosted cloud run
experience the managed cloud run and
you'll see it's exactly the same
experience as I had before but this time
I'm gonna pick one of these cloud run
regions and this is deploying it into
the fully this box this is deploying it
into the fully managed service
experience where there is no gke cluster
there's nothing actually backing this
and you see the developer experience is
the same so all that is really cool but
what about K native what about being
able to run the service in other places
as well so I'm going to show the last
step of this demo which is actually
using the the K native API the
underlying open source on an IBM cloud
cluster as just an example it could have
been any kubernetes cluster anywhere but
I happen to have one of those easily
available so I'm going to use g-cloud
run to get my service am all PDF service
you'll see here's the the key native API
ml for my service I scroll up you'll see
there's a bunch of metadata of course
but the spec is pretty simple it's just
saying to run the latest version of this
revision and for this particular image
this is the the key native API very
simple you and I will I've actually put
this into service study ml just to show
that I'm not lying and I will do Q
cuddle apply into my other cluster the
service tunnel and this is going to do
the same thing that the UI was doing
before create this K native service on
this kubernetes cluster and I can do get
a service and you'll see that service is
now up and running I have a URL that I
can access their service and their
thanks to the power of K native I have
the same thing running so we have the
same portability of the experience that
normal kubernetes would give you but I
didn't have to worry about any of the
details of how to program kubernetes how
to make it auto scale how to do all of
those developer complexity things that I
didn't want to do before Kay native
cloud run and Quadron ng k you have
taken care of that so as a developer I
can just focus on writing my code and
not be concerned with all of the other
details of what I have to worry about if
we could switch back to the slides
please
so to give you a little bit more example
of how all of this works in action you
need to give your thing to him I'd like
to bring up Daniel Larusso from gitlab
to show you how git lab has integrated
with cloud run on gke and Kay native to
provide a portable experience first hi
Thank You Ryan
so at good lab we couldn't agree more
kubernetes is the de facto platform for
running containers and we've worked to
integrate all of those workflows in our
product all right so serverless is no
different we believe k native is an
important part of enabling the developer
experience and basically really allowing
developers to focus on writing code and
applications and adding value and not
having to focus on maintaining
infrastructure and configuring it and
all of those things so as you know
gitlab provides a unified experience for
operators and developers where you can
manage both your code and your
infrastructure from a single app so
there's a lot of power in that so let's
see what that's all about can we switch
to demo - all right
so here I have my good lab project let's
head over to operations and kubernetes
so I see here that the operator has set
up a kubernetes cluster on my project
and Claire run on gke has been enabled
here I see that the domain that I
requested for my app has been configured
in this case get lab clout run so here's
where the benefits of get laps start to
become visible here I see that with a
single click an operator can configure
that domain to the issue of ingress
endpoint and behind the scenes what's
that's doing is that it's adding the
domain to a config map to resolve all
the requests to the service using this
domain so I didn't have to expose any
configuration on kubernetes anything
it's a single click up so that's really
great let's move on to the project here
and let's take a look and let's take a
look at how easy it is to deploy a
service on cloud run on GK so there are
two types of services that I could
deploy I could deploy a function as a
service or I could deploy a full service
app and key native will scale it up and
down based on on the requests so for
this demo I will go ahead and deploy a
function so I only need two templates
the first one is the get lab CI llamo
and basically this this contains a
reference to the Klat run CLI that we're
using that will take care of building
and deploying your cloud run service and
then the second template is the several
as Yamit so I only need this one if I'm
gonna deal with functions and here
basically it provides information about
my functions such as the name
description the runtime that I'm using
in this case is gonna be a trigger mesh
no J as run time and that's it so that's
really all I need to to get started so
the very next thing that I'm going to do
is I'm going to add the files that are
specific to my function so here I'm just
gonna add three files the first file is
Echo Dodge is this is a simple function
that will echo back whatever input I
give to it and the other two files are
packaged JSON files that hold a metadata
for my service so that's it let's go
ahead and add those to the project
let's give this a commit message here at
echo function files and push all right
so let's make sure that all those files
made it back to my repo properly great I
see that the echo directory made it here
and it contains all of the files that I
just pushed so this in turn will create
a CI pipeline that will actually take
care of building and deploying the K
native service so it takes about a
minute to do complete so let me show you
what it looks like when it's done here I
can see the whole process in a single
stage of building and deploying the
cloud run on GK service so when this
happens this will populate an entry in
my certainly in my server list page so
that's on their operations and server
lists and the entry on this page is
gonna be a reference to the K native
service so here we'll see soon as it
loads we'll see a couple of things that
are specific to the service all right so
I see here the service name the service
description and the endpoint where the
service is being served and that's it so
that means that my service is now out
there and I should be able to send the
request to it and hopefully will work
and it will echo back whatever input I
give to it so for this first test
let's give it this input hello from
Google next 29:19 here I'm just gonna
use curl so you see the content type the
request type and the endpoint so let's
go ahead and do that so here the service
is scaling from zero so it's gonna spawn
up whatever resources it needs and I see
that it echoed back this data so let's
try it a second time here this time I'll
pass it get lab service functions on
Klat run for GK so you see that that
second time it was a lot faster because
the resources have already been spun up
and then basically as you give it load
it will scale up and when there's no
load it will scale back down to zero so
here if we click on my service I'll see
more detail
I see because this is running on cloud
run for gke there's a kubernetes cluster
and I will see the scale for my function
so in this gate in this case I see that
is using only one pot as you give it
more traffic you will see more pots
spawn up here and very soon we'll add
the number of invocations that you have
for your functions so as you can see it
was very simple to deploy it as a
service from zero and while it's still
early you can see that there's a lot of
power in that and like Ryan said we
don't have to concern ourselves with
being experts in kubernetes so and this
is being added to get laps EE which is
open source so you can feel free to
contribute to any use cases that you may
need on top of it and that's all I have
back to mark I switch back to slides
Daniel walked us through some of the
benefits and the overview of the demo
and and kind of give us a good idea of
how we can partner using the K native
API s that are very open with broader
number of partners in the community that
enable whether it's CI CD whether it's
logging whether all the extra
capabilities that you might potentially
depend on when you were developing on
premise and how you want to use them in
a kind of more distributed environment
whether it's in a cloud or continued
developing on premise but using some of
the technologies that cloud run or
specifically K native enable so what I'm
gonna do now I'm gonna gonna go in and
maybe kind of highlight another use case
that captures some of the more kind of
real-life scenarios as when you're
developing a more micro service based
off a kind of solution so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna use a start with
a very simplistic use case where which
is a single service deployed on cloud
run that exposes the rest interface to
the outside world
that can be invoked with an image that's
then it's turning around and calling a
Google cloud vision API to get an
identification of an other logo that
might be included in an image what we're
gonna do then we're gonna say okay
that's great except
every in the world everybody in the
world is able to run my credits against
the vision API which is something I
probably don't want to enable too much
so we're going to front this with a yet
another micro service which is going to
provide authentication or using OAuth
against Google OAuth service and expose
simple UI also so that users can
interact with that API
much easier that's great except if
you're paying attention right now you're
quickly realizing that both of those
services are exposed to the outside
world so you probably all say hahahaha I
can just go around there I can continue
calling my original service and
everything is will be great so let's see
how a cloud run services on cloud run
cannot it can help you to deal with this
kind of situations you can switch to
demo one that's alright so I have a
simple image here you and I know what it
is I've seen a lot of hands raised
initially when we kicked off the session
talking about people who know what
kubernetes is so you probably know what
it is but in when we when machine asks
and looks at dirty image you might know
what it is so the vision API provides
one of its sub services that allow you
to identify logos so we're gonna use
this actually before we even go there
let's let's first of all deploy this
image I wouldn't want to run a rest
service against something that doesn't
exist so first of all we're gonna run it
looks a little complex because we kind
of including some of the additional
services so Ryan has deployed service
using UI I'm gonna show you how to do
this using G cloud exactly same
experience the same variables but but
the just different different tool so
obviously G cloud is the tool we're
gonna use run which is the service we we
are announcing here we're going to
deploy here's my creative service that
apparently always have to start with K
now and we're going to add a couple
additional variables we're gonna deploy
an image you've seen during the demos as
often for ease of demonstration kind of
deploy an image with latest which is
great for demonstration probably not
want to do that in real life you want a
specific hash a shot of the image there
represents
a state of that image that as it was
that it will allow you to benefit from
the auto-scaling without making with
without the worrying about that when
this when you deploy the service today
and the image and these solution has to
scale to not additional notes tomorrow
that you're putting a different version
of the image so this consistent same
version of the image is gonna be on
every single service and we also
providing a couple additional
environment variables in here like
release mode so let's do this now the
thing I like to point out here during
the demos is this is pretty fast when
you think about you know docker images
can can get pretty large how fast you do
this and how quickly you can deploy is
pretty impressive so what what cloud run
gave us here is a specific version so
the name of the service plus some unique
characters there and also give us URL I
have this entire cluster configure with
custom domain and an SSL Certificates so
we can actually kind of resemble real
more or a world scenario so let's back
go back to our curl and let's let's run
it so the simple thing we're gonna run a
JSON we're gonna post a JSON object
which is very simple has only an ID and
a URL and then we're gonna pipe it
through jQuery so we can have a little
more color over response so we see here
very quickly the service was running it
returned a identification it identified
that us kubernetes I'm actually
underselling division API vision API
returns a broad number of set of
features and capabilities sort of
features of that image including
attributes colors and other things I'm
just extracting one thing for ease of
demo but cloud vision API is pretty
pretty impressive service okay so what
we're gonna do now is there's you know
rest interface so it's great but let's
deploy that who are we let's deploy the
UI application so we can actually take a
look at it again much bigger command yes
there's more environment variables in
here but bottom line is we're gonna run
the exact same thing and when that is
done great we can actually switch to the
browser and start using
can you guys see it yeah
so clearly an application created for
demonstration purposes there's no know
much there but one thing that we can do
is we can easily log in here into a
service I'm gonna use my personal one so
I'm not exposing any Google stuff here
and we have a nice UI oh I have to go
shopping I think it's the same t-shirt
that was wearing when I was taking this
picture all right so big back to our
kubernetes image we can run this through
the same same UI but like we said there
is this problem that I can continue
coming back to my curl and just running
it so clearly not working as intended
I'm gonna come back to this UI in here
we have this new version let's refresh
this because we just deployed it on your
version so now you see the three met two
minutes ago I deployed a new one there's
number of features here logging details
you see the environment variables you
can actually see the Yama file the Jason
that Ryan has deployed across IBM cloud
and ours you can consume the same thing
with environment variables the one thing
I want to highlight here that in
addition to these other capabilities you
can actually come in here and very
easily change this to an internal
service so let's see let's wait for this
to finish let's come over here and first
of all clear this and maybe do a little
verbose alright so curl is a lot more
verbose but the important thing is over
here first of all the service was 404 so
not only we've introduced like it's not
like we put some kind of token or
security on it
we literally remove the route to it it's
not accessible from outside world the
other thing you should notice here that
automatically we we recognize that this
traffic supports HTTP 2 so we've
upgraded that service to http 2 so let's
now see if our UI continues working
because if we just shut down the
back-end service that's probably not
what we want it right now let's see I
don't think we used YouTube before you
there it is so our service is able to
use this service the backend service
internally inside of the cluster by
discovering its internal URL and
consuming that versus using the external
that's a great capability that allows
you to start mixing much different
services
and you continue benefitting from the
East your mesh that's running underneath
to give you a telemetry access policy
request paths and all that
in fact East Joe request path pattern is
actually exact request path access
pattern is actually used in here to
deliver that very capability all right
so let's switch to slides so what we've
done here just to recap we've deployed
number of services actually going a
little further what I've done he
deployed a yet another service that's
providing a metering so we actually keep
a state of each which users request and
we persist them into fires fire store
API that so even if you were to go to
the UI and start using it you know
thousand of times I will shut you down
after one hundred of Corey's per day so
we have number of back-end services that
are internally accessible only
internally there are accessible to the
front UI as a backing service but the
front UI is the only service that's
exposed externally it allows users and
forces them to authenticate a little
more real world scenario of how you
would develop those applications and the
beauty of this is that you can continue
keep building on that you can continue
adding using cloud cloud run you can
keep on G key you can Club continue
building those services and behind the
scene if so if the UI is not exposing
something you can use cube CTL to manage
this as if this was normal kubernetes
service for that was deployed by you
alright so Ryan tell us again about what
the different options we have and where
we can run these services on using key
native Beck services so thank you mark
that was I think your cool demo
everybody else think that was a cool
demo
no I'll beg for applause that's fine
it's a product manager job uh so circle
us where you want it with key native and
Claude Ron you know I want to emphasize
the the portability aspect here because
really what we're trying to do is make
it so that you can have the developer
experience of serverless in any
environment where you want to enable
that experience we know that not
everybody fits into the mold of what a
fully hosted service option can offer
and that there are lots of reasons why
customers want to stay on gke
on kubernetes and run on kerbin at ease
really anywhere but the developer
experience shouldn't have to change as a
result of that you should be able to get
the same experience for how you write
code being idiomatic as Mark said my
favorite word across all the different
ecosystems so that you're not just the
workload can be portable like I showed
being able to deploy the same thing in
multiple places but that the skills can
transfer that the developer experience
can be portable so that what I learned
today using cloud run on gke can on my
next project be applied to cloud run and
on the next project be applied to an
on-premises cluster and so you know
we've announced these products cloud run
cloud run on g ke which are in beta
today i really encourage everybody to
take go out and try these out today and
give them a try and look at a can a tip
as well if you have a kid Native
communities cluster sorry where you're
interested in running service workloads
I talked about the story so there's
there's a bunch of related sessions of
course this is afternoon on Thursday so
almost all of these have already
happened they're all going to be on
YouTube in a matter of a few days so
please go back and watch them if you're
interested more in about K native or in
the overall cloud round vision I do want
to plug though the svr 305 is happening
this afternoon which is a deep dive on K
native eventing so everything that we
talked about today is on the serving
path and being able to auto scale your
workloads but if you're familiar with
how we define server lists and
and one of the slides that mark talked
about there's that event-driven piece
which we sort of didn't talk about a
whole lot today because it's still
coming through kini to eventing and
Sevilla and Mark who are going to be
presenting about the vision of where
eventing is going as well as some really
cool demos showing how eventing can be
used today so definitely check that out
and maybe one thing to Audi here is that
clearly this is better a better product
cloud run on is still in better right
now in key native itself is 0-5 release
a lot of the use cases that you're
trying to address specifically
on-premise are something that we would
be very interested to understand better
and and see how can it have solves for
those so if you if you are at all
dealing with kubernetes and service it
seems like something that Kenny and
cloud run can help you with please use
some of those URLs in here including
there are some feedbacks and Twitter as
was Canadian dev has added some
additional links you can use to kind of
give us some ideas of what's missing or
what else can we add to cloud run itself
to make this more kind of
appropriate for some of the use cases
you're trying to solve
[Music]